こっち派同士のです皆さんアニメはお好きですかアニメアニメが大好きです最近は
ちょっと見る時間がなくてあんまり見れてないんですけどもみなさんラブライブってご
存じでしょうかだブライぶっていうのはね音ノ木坂学院という学校にするの9人生徒が
学校の危機を救うためにそして自らを変えるためにスクールアイドルとなって方
どんどん成長していくというアイドルと見せかけての熱血家彫刻
燃えるハートフルアニメでございます姉時代は終わっちゃって結構碑が建ってるんです
よ結構もう終わってラブライブですが結構冷めてきてるんですけどもなんと水最近の
ラブライブの新しい最新作というか続編みたいな感じでラブライブサンシャインという
のが始まりました
ッパ待ってましたもう最後のライブっていうのがあってそれもう終わって本当に悲しく
なった悲しかったし正直
ラブライブでその流れが一つに終わって俺はちょっとラブライブ実が覚めだところあっ
たんですよ
大好きだけどね大好きなんですけどダメですがちょっと冷めてたところがあって見てた
ところがあったんですけども今回はグランジュサンシャインっていう新しいアニメがな
グラブで始まりまして内容はどんなのかと言いますとこの赤ちゃんたついこのミューズ
の急にラブライブで主人公とか9人達成
のお話がも終わってて水タンクの9人のお話の後の話でございますのでラブラブ
サンシャインがこの本の火山立つところでてこなくて全く別の主人公全く別の端らしい
キャラクターたちでお話が展開されていきますこうねやっぱこういろんな意見がある
わけですよやっぱラブライバーなドライブで終わっ
欲しかったあんまり語ると怒られそうだなこれぐらいにしておきましたあまり僕が音が
偉そうに言ってもあれなんですけどもとりあえず学ぶライブというものがですね
サンシャインという新しい名前を付けてまた帰ってきたというわけで
じゃあここで俺は全国の地方の人に言いたいお前等俺も同じ教授立つオアニメガバン
にゃ
あー穂乃果ちゃんアニメがあまり高級な方ともアニメはなんでもやってるんですけども
地図をカット富山県とかもうほんとポークの地元とかだぞ田舎の方とかはねテレビを見
てもやってねーが多いんですよ
いやマジでねもうね分かるよみんなの気持ちはから静岡にでも富山に行ってまで見れ
ない兄人はとても多いして時間とかもめちゃくちゃだったりするんでをラブライブ
サンシャインがやってる
どうかも僕正直わからないですしぞーかねこれからちょっと田舎の人はねアニメに対し
てちょっとも弱いんですけども
今回なんとなんとラブライブサンシャインが youtube で
ちゃんとさん日本語でしゃべるはいというわけでラブライブサンシャインがなんと
ファンデーションの公式チャンネルで見ることでギューッ
俺本当にありファンタリアホイールこういう
こういうつかな youtube をれず youtube でさあマジで安泰って
本当にはリューってよとに youtube ね youtube でいまだ課題でも
ラブライブ3社の一番にはまだニャーまでしか出てないのか未だに家までしか出ないん
ですけどもにはがもう全部24分が全部見れますラブラインサン参院はね実は静岡県が
もう
チーフロケ地になってるんでちょっと親近感があって楽しみなんですけどもうそれでも
この youtube を見てる皆さんも gt でもラブラブサンシャイン
見れるのでちょっと
みてねもうまずらがライブを見てほしいましてまずラベルサンシャインが英中ことを
連れておらね今回お伝えしたかった本
とっさに育った子の命チャンネルでお伝えした
はいというわけですぐラブラブサンシャイン見ていきましょう一番とにはが今のところ
ありますスタート裏今から見ますその1はビルのでし
[音楽]
ああ鳥肌が
立っていなかったあれ
[音楽]
ん
ズラー
me
ん
ぷっ
uh
[音楽]
はぁちょっと目に砂が入って泣いてしまいました
いやもう何かねその本の形に立つミューズがなんかやっぱり凄かったんだなって思い
ました
いや本当にキモい人と思われちゃいと言うラブライブサンシャインですねえっとどこで
泣いたかって言われるとですからプライベサンシャインの中でラブライブのこの
ミューズたちのメンバーの歌とか流れると
やっぱこうなんか思い出しちゃいますね入れるとずっとヤバイ人と思われそうだが入っ
てゆけでラブライブが好きだった方も食べみんなチェックしてると思うんですけども
ぜひ youtube でも見れますのでな触れる三者にチェックしてみてくださいで
これなーまで全どうかなちょっと皆さんにお伝えしたかったなって肌でございます
ラベル三者にぜひ見てくださいちょっとまたラブラブ熱が薄くなってきました水京と
れいちゃんでした
取れないあっちゃんじゃんっ
4日
th
いいえいます
[音楽]
ています